OK, this just in. People don't like to admit it when they mess up. It's true for little kids, true for adults, and maybe especially true for politicians. In just the last few weeks, President Trump has refused to apologize for calling for the deaths of the Central Park Five, even though somebody else admitted to that crime, and DNA evidence confirmed that version of the story.
好的，最新消息。人们在搞砸事情时不喜欢承认。这对小孩来说是这样，对大人来说也是这样，对政客来说可能尤其如此。就在过去几周里，特朗普总统拒绝为他曾呼吁判处“中央公园五人帮”死刑一事道歉，尽管已经有其他人承认犯下了那起罪行，且DNA证据也证实了那个版本的说法。
Joe Biden has refused to apologize for saying this about a segregationist senator back in the '70s, quote, "He never called me boy. He always called me son." Presidential candidate and senator Cory Booker called on Biden to apologize for it. Biden refused to apologize, called on Booker to apologize for the very thought that the remark might have been wrongheaded.
乔·拜登拒绝为他在70年代针对一位种族隔离主义参议员发表的言论道歉，引用如下：“他从来没叫我‘小黑子’。他总是叫我‘孩子’。”总统候选人兼参议员科里·布克曾呼吁拜登为此道歉。拜登拒绝道歉，反而要求布克为认为其言论可能不妥这种想法而道歉。
And when politicians do apologize, you know how it goes. It's usually the kind of insincere, I regret the error. I meant no harm, I will do better kind of thing. Like the apology the Prime Minister of Hong Kong issued this month after two million people took to the streets to protest how cozy she is with mainland China. As a chief executive she said, I still have more to learn, and to do better to balance diverse interests and listen to people from all walks of life. Just imagine for a second your partner or your spouse saying something like that to you with that tone. You would not feel reassured that they were really sorry.
当政客们道歉时，你知道会发生什么。通常都是那种不真诚的、我对此感到遗憾。我本无意伤害，我会做得更好之类的。就像香港行政长官本月在两百万人走上街头抗议她与中国大陆关系过于亲密后发表的道歉。作为行政长官，她说，我还有很多需要学习的地方，需要做得更好以平衡不同的利益，倾听各行各业人们的声音。试想一下，你的伴侣或配偶用那种语气对你说这样的话。你绝对不会感到被安抚，也不会觉得他们是真的感到抱歉。
OK, so years ago when Barack Obama was still president-- and I remember he was apologizing for some remark he'd made about small town America. And around the same time, Hillary Clinton was apologizing for saying that she flew into Bosnia under sniper fire, which did not happen-- I was interviewing this guy about something else completely. And somehow we got into the subject of this whole apology business.
好的，多年前巴拉克·奥巴马还是总统的时候——我记得他当时在为他针对美国小城镇发表的某些言论道歉。大约在同一时间，希拉里·克林顿也在为她说自己是在狙击手火力下飞抵波斯尼亚一事道歉，但这并没有发生——当时我正在采访这个人谈论其他完全无关的事情。不知怎么的，我们谈到了道歉这一整件事。
And the guy has two daughters. They were both around 13 years old back then. And he told me that whenever one of his daughters does something to the other, and he tells him to apologize as their parent, usually, the apology is fake-- just pro forma fake, the kid version of the politician's non-apology apology. And what do you do with that?
那个人有两个女儿。当时她们大约都是13岁左右。他告诉我，每当他的一个女儿对另一个做了什么，作为父母的他让她们道歉时，通常那个道歉都是虚假的——只是例行公事的虚假，这就是儿童版的政客式“非道歉式的道歉”。你对此能做什么呢？
Because how do you make somebody actually feel sorry for something they don't feel sorry for? I mean, there they are. And you're like, say you're sorry. Say it like you mean it. And they don't mean it, and they're not going to. They don't yet have the empathy. Trying to explain to one of them, look, the way your sister feels is they go through life, they share with you. And then when you aren't generous with them, that makes them feel-- you're trying to explain it like this.
因为你怎么能让一个人对他们并不感到抱歉的事情真正感到抱歉呢？我的意思是，她们就在那儿。你对她们说，说对不起。说得好像你是真心的一样。但她们不是真心的，而且她们也不会是。她们还没有那种同理心。试图向其中一个解释，你看，你姐姐现在的感受是她们一起经历生活，她们与你分享。然后当你对她们不够慷慨时，这让她们觉得——你试图这样解释。
And you can see the look on their eye, like this cold steely look. Like I hear what you're saying. I hear your little fable. I'm just not buying it. And I don't know. They'll do lip service to it. They'll kind of sigh and shrug, and sort of, in a sense, allow that, perhaps that's the case. And then they take another shot at the apology.
你可以看到她们眼中的神情，那种冰冷坚硬的目光。好像在说，我听到了你在说什么。我听到了你讲的那些小寓言。但我根本不买账。我不知道。她们会对此进行口头敷衍。她们会叹气耸耸肩，在某种意义上承认，也许是那样吧。然后她们会再尝试道歉一次。
But as a parent, don't you feel like, well, OK, if all I'm going to get is lip service, at least I'm going to get the lip service. At least they recognize--
但作为父母，你不觉得，好吧，如果我得到的只是口头敷衍，至少我也得到了口头敷衍。至少她们承认了——
Yes, sir.
是的，长官。
--our moral code.
——我们的道德准则。
Even if your heart's not in this, I want to watch you go through the motions. This is what people do when they really are sorry.
即使你的内心并非如此，我也想看着你走过场。这就是当人们真正感到抱歉时会做的事情。
See, but that makes me feel more sympathetic to politicians or to this act which actually, usually fills me with contempt. I feel like, well, at least the politician is pretending and acknowledging, yes, there is a moral code. They don't feel sorry, but they'll acknowledge that someone should feel sorry. And I feel like, well, if that's what we're going to get out of our politicians, well, OK. I guess it's not what I want, but I can kind of live with that.
你看，但这让我对政客或这种行为产生了更多的同情，而这实际上通常只会让我感到蔑视。我觉得，好吧，至少这位政客是在假装并承认，是的，存在一种道德准则。他们并不感到抱歉，但他们会承认某人应该感到抱歉。我觉得，好吧，如果这就是我们能从政客那里得到的，那也行。我想这不是我想要的，但我可以勉强接受。
Yeah. Well, I don't know if you're familiar with all the details of that Bible story about David and Bathsheba. And it's almost this funny modern politics story, right?
是的。嗯，我不知道你是否熟悉《圣经》中大卫和拔示巴故事的所有细节。这几乎是一个有趣的现代政治故事，对吧？
No, I don't know this one.
不，我不知道这个故事。
Oh, OK. Well, so here's King David, powerful king of Israel, and he basically commits adultery in office. He sees a woman that he can have because of his power, who's not his wife, and arranges her to come to the palace and has his way with her. And then, the story's going to break. And her husband's going to find out. And he, in a very modern way, tries to quell the story, quash it, before it gets out.
噢，好的。那么这就是大卫王，强大的以色列国王，他基本上在职期间犯下了通奸罪。他因为自己的权力看到了一个可以拥有的女人，她不是他的妻子，便安排她来到宫殿并占有了她。然后，这个故事即将曝光。她的丈夫也会发现。于是他以一种非常现代的方式，试图在故事传开之前平息它、压制它。
He has her husband sent to the front lines of battle, where he gets killed. He does everything he can to hope that he can just actually hide it. He does not feel sorry about it. And he really digs himself in deep. And time goes on. And a prophet becomes aware of this divinely and comes to confront David on it.
他让她的丈夫被派往前线作战，在那里他被杀害了。他尽其所能希望能够真正掩盖这件事。他对此并不感到抱歉。而且他真的陷得很深。时间流逝。一位先知通过神启得知了此事，并前来与大卫对质。
And what does he do? He tells him a story. He gets him engaged in this little fable about somebody who has a pet lamb, a poor man with a pet lamb that he loves like a pet. And that a rich man goes in and gets that lamb and prepares it for a meal. Because of his power, he's able to-- the poor man's like a serf who lives on his land, so the rich man is just like, hey--
他做了什么？他讲了一个故事。他让他参与进这个关于某人拥有一只宠物羊的小寓言里，一个穷人有一只像宠物一样疼爱的羊。而一个富人进去夺走了那只羊，把它做成了餐食。因为他的权力，他能够——那个穷人就像生活在他土地上的农奴，所以富人只是说，嘿——
I'm taking that.
我要拿走那个。
Yeah, because it's-- you know, everything you have is mine. So it's this really awful thing of something that someone else valued very highly was valued very low by the rich man just because of his power. And but Nathan's not telling him the story like it's a fable. He's telling him like this is happening in your kingdom. What are you going to do about it?
是的，因为它是——你知道，你拥有的一切都是我的。所以这是一件非常糟糕的事情，别人非常珍视的东西被富人仅仅因为他的权力而视为草芥。但是拿单讲这个故事时并不是把它当作寓言。他是说这正在你的王国里发生。你打算对此做些什么？
David gets all enraged on behalf of the victim and says, bring him here. We're going to do justice on him. We're going to see this done right. We're going to bring that rich man here, and we're going to punish him to the full extent of the law. And so David is demanding justice for the perpetrator. And the prophet looks at him and says, you are the man.
大卫代表受害者大发雷霆，说，把他带到这里来。我们要对他伸张正义。我们要让这件事得到妥善解决。我们要把那个富人带到这里来，我们要依法从严惩处他。所以大卫在为罪犯要求正义。先知看着他说，你就是那个人。
And that does it. Then David really gets it, and he comes apart. And he has a very genuine apology and repentance. I mean, but he does really end up paying for it. And he's a much better king afterward. And so if you could sit down Clinton or Obama-- and I don't know, you'd have to do something like that, maybe.
这招真管用。大卫真的明白了，他崩溃了。他进行了非常真诚的道歉和悔改。我是说，但他最终确实付出了代价。之后他成了一位好得多的国王。所以如果你能让克林顿或奥巴马坐下来——我不知道，你可能得做点类似的事情。
What's sad is that they both know this story. They're always talking about how they're always going to church.
可悲的是，他们都知道这个故事。他们总是在谈论他们总是去教堂。
Yeah. [LAUGHS] That was a good point.
是的。[笑声] 那说得好。
They've already heard this story.
他们已经听过这个故事了。
Yeah. You wonder if one of their pastors will sit them down, tell them that story, and then say, you are the man.
是的。你真想知道他们的牧师中是否有人会让他们坐下来，讲那个故事，然后说，你就是那个人。
Well, from WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, Mistakes Were Made-- stories of people apologizing in that way that amounts to not apologizing at all, not accepting responsibility for the things they've done. Our show today in two acts-- Act One, You're Cold as Ice. Act Two, You're Willing to Sacrifice Our Love. Stay with us.
好的，这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ的《这一美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天我们的节目主题是“犯了错”——讲述人们以那种等同于根本没有道歉的方式进行道歉的故事，没有为他们所做的事情承担责任。我们今天的节目分为两幕——第一幕，你冷若冰霜。第二幕，你愿意牺牲我们的爱。请继续收听。
Act One, You're Cold as Ice. So many scientific advances begin with amateur enthusiasts. Or is that enthusiasts? Whatever. I'm talking about people who form little groups to explore new scientific ideas like robots, or computers, or just whatever. This story is about a group like that and the guy who led them. Sam Shaw tells the story.
第一幕，你冷若冰霜。许多科学进步始于业余爱好者。或者说是爱好者？管他呢。我在说那些组成小组探索新科学理念的人，比如机器人、计算机，或者其他什么。这个故事是关于这样一个小组以及领导他们的人。萨姆·肖讲述了这个故事。
It was the 1960s, the decade of the first heart transplant and the first working laser. New antibiotics gave the Surgeon General such a jolt of confidence, he announced to Congress that the time had come, and I quote, "to close the book on infectious diseases." It was against this backdrop of high-flying optimism that a Michigan College professor named Robert Ettinger wrote a book posing a simple question-- what if death itself was just another disease-- generally fatal, but not necessarily incurable?
那是20世纪60年代，心脏移植手术和第一台工作激光器出现的十年。新的抗生素让卫生局局长信心大增，他向国会宣布时机已经到来，我引用，“结束传染病的历史书”。正是在这种高昂乐观的背景下，一位名叫罗伯特·埃廷格的密歇根大学教授写了一本书，提出了一个简单的问题——如果死亡本身只是另一种疾病呢——通常致命，但不一定无法治愈？
His theory went like this. If you could freeze somebody at the exact moment of clinical death, maybe, just maybe, in 50 years or 100 years or 1,000, the doctors of the future could bring him back to life. This was cryonics or cryonic suspension. And groups of enthusiasts began to spring up here and there, which is how Bob Nelson got involved.
他的理论是这样的。如果你能在临床死亡的那一刻冻结某人，也许，仅仅是也许，在50年、100年或1000年后，未来的医生就能让他起死回生。这就是人体冷冻术或冷冻悬浮。爱好者团体开始到处涌现，这就是鲍勃·尼尔森如何参与进来的方式。
I was on the freeway in a traffic jam-- very common here in California. And it came on the radio that there was going to be the first meeting of the Suspended Animation Group at Helen Kline's house. And I remember going there thinking that I'm probably not going to be allowed in, because I'm not a scientist. But at least I'll get to see some of the scientists. And I went in. I was allowed in, and I came out voted president.
我在高速公路上遇上了堵车——这在加州很常见。收音机里说在海伦·克莱恩家要举行第一次“悬浮动画小组”会议。我记得去那里的时候心想，我可能不会被允许进入，因为我不是科学家。但至少我能见到一些科学家。我进去了。我被允许进入，出来时被选为了主席。
Bob had no medical or scientific training whatsoever. Hadn't even finished high school. He was a 30-year-old TV repairman with a wife and three kids. But he was charming, the kind of charm where you like him because he lets you know in 100 ways that he likes you. After a few hours with him, he's hugging you goodbye. And Bob sincerely believed that cryonics was going to save millions of lives, and that belief was infectious.
鲍勃没有任何医学或科学训练。甚至连高中都没读完。他是一个30岁的电视修理工，有妻子和三个孩子。但他很有魅力，那种因为他通过一百种方式让你知道他喜欢你而让你也喜欢他的魅力。和他相处几个小时后，他会拥抱你告别。鲍勃真诚地相信人体冷冻术将拯救数百万人的生命，而这种信念具有感染力。
He did some press, local TV and radio. Turned out he was a really good salesman.
他做了一些新闻报道，当地电视和广播。结果证明他是一个非常好的推销员。
And it did. It took off like a cyclone. It was stunning. I remember once going into a restaurant, and I was at the urinal and overheard two guys talking, saying, you know who that is? That's the guy that freezes people. And the other guy said, why does he do that? And I thought it was just bizarre to be in that situation where you're famous for something that you don't know quite how it happened.
确实如此。它像旋风一样流行起来。令人震惊。我记得有一次走进一家餐厅，我在小便池旁听到两个人在谈论，说，你知道那是谁吗？那就是那个冷冻人的家伙。另一个人说，他为什么要那么做？我觉得身处那种因为某些你甚至不知道怎么发生的事情而变得出名的情况下，简直太怪异了。
The members of Bob's group weren't experts. They were just fans of an idea. As you'd expect, many were older people, some of them sick and thinking about their own deaths. They set up a non-profit, the Cryonics Society of California. And before long, they'd drafted a lineup of scientific advisors. At this point, nobody had actually been frozen yet, and the scientists set one condition for their participation-- that nobody try, not yet. They wanted to take things slow, conduct research, publish papers.
鲍勃小组的成员不是专家。他们只是一个理念的粉丝。正如你所料，许多是老年人，其中一些人病重并考虑着自己的死亡。他们成立了一个非营利组织，加州人体冷冻协会。没过多久，他们就起草了一份科学顾问名单。此时，还没有人真正被冷冻过，科学家们为他们的参与设定了一个条件——不准任何人尝试，还不到时候。他们想慢慢来，进行研究，发表论文。
And that was fine with Bob until he got a call from the son of a psychology professor who was dying of cancer, a man who couldn't wait for the research to pan out. His name was James Bedford. Dr. Bedford wanted to be frozen, and he wondered if the Cryonics Society could help him. So Bob says he got on the phone with the godfather of the movement.
这在鲍勃看来没问题，直到他接到一位正死于癌症的心理学教授儿子的电话，那个人等不及研究成果了。他的名字叫詹姆斯·贝德福德。贝德福德博士想被冷冻，他想知道人体冷冻协会能否帮助他。所以鲍勃说他给该运动的教父打了电话。
Well, I called Robert Ettinger that night, and I told him what had happened. And he said, oh my god, this is the biggest thing that's happened in the cryonics program. And so Ettinger said, we need to go ahead and do it. And I said, but we'll lose the scientific advisory council. He said, maybe not all of them. And if we do, we'll get them again. He said, there's nothing that will push the program of cryonics forward than the freezing of the first man.
嗯，那天晚上我打了给罗伯特·埃廷格，告诉了他发生的事情。他说，天哪，这是人体冷冻计划中发生的最重要的事情。所以埃廷格说，我们需要继续做下去。我说，但我们会失去科学顾问委员会。他说，也许不会全部失去。如果我们失去了，我们会再次找回他们。他说，没有什么能比冷冻第一个人更能推动人体冷冻计划的发展了。
Were you right? Did you lose them?
你是对的吗？你失去他们了吗？
Absolutely. Lost every one of them the next day.
绝对失去了。第二天就失去了他们中的每一个人。
So Bob assembled a team of doctors to carry out the freezing. Though when Dr. Bedford died on January 12, 1967, they were all caught off guard. Dr. Bedford's nurse had to run up and down the block collecting ice from the home freezers of neighbors. Cryonics was still just a theory, and the proceedings had the slightly manic quality of a local theater production forced to open a couple of weeks early.
于是鲍勃组建了一个医生团队来进行冷冻。尽管当贝德福德博士于1967年1月12日去世时，他们都被打了个措手不及。贝德福德博士的护士不得不跑遍街区，从邻居的家用冷柜里收集冰块。人体冷冻术还只是一个理论，整个过程带有那种被迫提前几周开演的当地剧院制作的轻微躁狂感。
A half a year later, when a member of their own group turned up at the morgue, wearing a medical bracelet saying she was supposed to be frozen, Bob wasn't much better prepared. Her name was Marie Sweet. And among the things she left when she died, there was a photograph someone had taken of her 27 years earlier, along with a handwritten message. It said, "This is as I wish to be restored."
半年后，当他们小组的一名成员出现在停尸房，带着写着她应该被冷冻的医疗手环时，鲍勃并没有做好多少准备。她的名字叫玛丽·斯威特。在她去世时留下的东西中，有一张某人在27年前为她拍的照片，以及一封手写的留言。上面写着，“这就是我希望被复原的样子。”
Bob called a couple of student embalmers with access to equipment at the mortuary college, and they performed the freezing the only place they could, in the Cryonics Society office on two desks pushed together and covered with a sheet.
鲍勃叫了几个可以接触到殡葬学院设备的实习防腐师，他们就在他们唯一能做的地方进行了冷冻，在人体冷冻协会办公室里，两张桌子拼在一起，上面盖着床单。
I was a nervous wreck because I'm thinking, I don't know how many violations I'm committing here. For example, a dead body legally can only be moved by a mortician. And then I had no idea if I was committing any violations by having the body up in our offices, and putting her on ice there, and then carrying her down the stairs. It was all just really peculiar.
我当时快神经崩溃了，因为我在想，我不知道我在这里犯了多少违规行为。例如，死尸在法律上只能由殡葬业者移动。而且我根本不知道把尸体放在我们的办公室里，把她放在冰上，然后把她搬下楼，是否触犯了任何规定。这一切真的很奇特。
One challenge with cryonics is that the freezing process itself can do a lot of damage to the body. Living cells are full of water, and when water freezes, it expands, like a house in winter where the pipes burst. To minimize the damage, Bob and his team replace the blood with special chemicals, a process called perfusion. Meanwhile, they packed ice around the head and body-- a lot of ice.
人体冷冻术的一个挑战是冷冻过程本身会对身体造成很大的损害。活细胞充满了水，当水结冰时，它会膨胀，就像冬天的房子管道破裂一样。为了最大限度地减少损害，鲍勃和他的团队用特殊的化学物质代替了血液，这个过程称为灌注。同时，他们把冰块包裹在头部和身体周围——大量的冰。
The goal was to get Marie into a giant stainless steel container cooled by liquid nitrogen. A cryonics buff in Arizona had started building capsules for exactly this purpose. That's where Dr. Bedford ended up, sent there by his son after the first freezing. But it wasn't clear where to send Marie. The Cryonics Society had no place to keep a frozen body. For all they knew, centuries might pass before she could be thawed out and brought back to life. Which is to say, they needed someplace really permanent. That was going to cost a lot of money.
目标是将玛丽放入一个由液氮冷却的巨型不锈钢容器中。亚利桑那州的一位人体冷冻迷为了这个目的开始建造胶囊。这就是贝德福德博士最终去的地方，在第一次冷冻后被他的儿子送到了那里。但不清楚该把玛丽送到哪里。人体冷冻协会没有地方存放冰冻的尸体。据他们所知，可能几个世纪过去她才能被解冻并恢复生命。换句话说，他们需要一个真正永久的地方。那将花费很多钱。
Marie Sweet's husband managed to scrape together a few hundred dollars-- that's it. And the society was broke. What the society did have was a lot of enthusiastic members, all of them hoping to be suspended. Bob figured he'd let them decide whether to keep Marie frozen. It wasn't a very tough room.
玛丽·斯威特的丈夫设法凑了几百美元——就这么多。而且协会没钱了。协会确实有很多热情的成员，他们都希望被悬浮。鲍勃想他会让人们决定是否继续冷冻玛丽。那不是一个很难应付的房间。
They all said, yeah, yeah, go ahead, Bob. Yeah, go ahead. Oh, OK. So I should have said, well, is anybody going to help here? Or is it just me? And but it turned out it was just me. And then I get to the point where I begin to realize that this was me. I had the power, the decision, to say, OK, we're going to give up on Marie, which we should have done in hindsight.
他们都说，是啊，是啊，继续吧，鲍勃。是啊，继续吧。哦，好吧。所以我不该说，嗯，有人要帮忙吗？还是只有我？结果发现确实只有我。然后我意识到这全是我。我有权力，决定权，说，好吧，我们要放弃玛丽，事后看来我们确实应该这样做。
But I kept thinking that it's going to work. So it just seemed that it was worth going just a little bit further. I never intended with Marie Sweet to forever keep her in preservation at my own expense. No. I just felt for a while to see what happened next.
但我一直认为这会成功的。所以看起来值得再多走一小步。我从来没有打算为了玛丽·斯威特而自费永远保持她的保存状态。不。我只是觉得先观察一段时间看看会发生什么。
This very reasonable position led Bob into a lot of very unreasonable decisions over the next few years-- decisions he's still explaining decades later. And what happened next is that another member of the society died.
这种非常合理的立场导致鲍勃在接下来的几年里做出了许多非常不合理的决定——他几十年后仍在解释这些决定。接下来发生的事情是，协会的另一名成员去世了。
Now Helen Kline-- let me preface by saying-- was, for me, very special. This was the lady that introduced me to the concept of cryonics. She was the one that had that first meeting. She just somehow put a spell on me. You know? I just loved her.
现在海伦·克莱恩——让我先说明一下——对我来说非常特别。就是这位女士把我引入了人体冷冻术的概念。她就是那个举行第一次会议的人。她不知怎么地给我施了咒语。你知道吗？我只是爱她。
The society already had one body on its hands and no real plan of action. Like Marie Sweet, Helen Kline had died more or less penniless, leaving no funds to pay for a proper cryonic suspension. But the truth is Bob liked these people, and he didn't want to let them down. And who knew? Maybe cryonics would be huge, and there'd be money in it someday.
协会手里已经有了一具尸体，却没有真正的行动计划。像玛丽·斯威特一样，海伦·克莱恩死时几乎身无分文，没留下钱来支付适当的冷冻悬浮费用。但事实是鲍勃喜欢这些人，他不想让他们失望。谁知道呢？也许人体冷冻术会变得很大，总有一天会有钱赚。
Once again, Bob put the question to the group. And once again, they all agreed. Their friend deserved a shot at a second life. So Helen Kline followed Marie Sweet to a mortuary in the city of Buena Park, where Bob had jerry-rigged a temporary storage container-- basically, a wooden box lined with polyurethane.
鲍勃再次把问题抛给了小组成员。他们再次达成了一致。他们的朋友理应得到第二次生命的机会。所以海伦·克莱恩跟随玛丽·斯威特去了布埃纳帕克市的一家殡仪馆，鲍勃在那里简陋地搭建了一个临时存储容器——基本上就是一个内衬聚氨酯的木箱。
Actually, what the wooden box is, is when they ship a casket, it's the outer box-- the wooden box that they ship them in. And we would put styrofoam on the sides and on the top, and they make excellent refrigeration units.
实际上，这个木箱是他们运送棺材时的外包装——他们运送棺材用的那个木箱。我们在侧面和顶部放上泡沫塑料，它们就成了极好的冷藏装置。
In other words, a giant cooler filled with a lot of dry ice. The problem was dry ice is expensive. So he made what seemed like a simple decision at the time.
换句话说，就是一个装满了大量干冰的巨型冷却器。问题是干冰很贵。所以他做了一个当时看起来很简单决定。
We had a container with a lady in dry ice already. It didn't cost anymore to put this little lady in there. Once we put Helen Kline in-- she was a tiny little thing, and so was Marie.
我们已经有一个装有女士的干冰容器了。把这位小个子女士放进去并不会多花钱。一旦我们放进了海伦·克莱恩——她是个小巧玲珑的人，玛丽也是。
Maintaining the cooler was a big job, but Bob didn't really see an alternative. Every week or so, he put hundreds of pounds of dry ice in the backseat of his little vintage Porsche and drove two hours from Woodland Hills to the mortuary in Buena Park, where the bodies were stored. Not in some state of the art permanent facility, remember. Here's Joe Klockgether, the mortician at the facility.
维护冷却器是一项大工程，但鲍勃真的没看到其他选择。大约每隔一周，他就会把几百磅的干冰放在他那辆小型老式保时捷的后座上，驱车两个小时从伍德兰希尔斯到布埃纳帕克的殡仪馆，那里存放着尸体。记住，不是什么最先进的永久设施。这是乔·克洛克盖瑟，该设施的殡葬师。
It was in the garage that I had them. So I have to say the storage facility because when you say storage facility, you think of something much neater. But it was the garage, but it didn't make any difference, really, except that, oh, you kept them in a garage. That doesn't sound good.
我把它们放在车库里。所以我不得不说是存储设施，因为当你提到存储设施时，你会想到更整洁的地方。但那是个车库，实际上也没什么区别，除了，哦，你把它们放在车库里。这听起来不太好。
But yeah, I was anxious to get them out of here. Bob, come on, I got to use my garage. I got things I want to do. I don't want to keep doing this here. And I don't want to play around with the health department.
但是是的，我急于把它们弄出去。鲍勃，拜托，我得用我的车库。我有想做的事情。我不想一直在这里这样做。而且我不想和卫生部门玩猫捉老鼠。
See, there's a term, temporary storage. They don't really clarify what temporary means, but you or I know temporary doesn't mean forever. Temporary-- something should be down on the road. You should have some kind of a date.
你看，有个词叫临时存储。他们并没有真正说明临时是什么意思，但你或我知道临时并不意味着永远。临时——路上应该有某种安排。你应该有一个日期。
It was at this point, with Bob dodging Joe Klockgether, and Joe Klockgether dodging the health department, that a third member of the society died unexpectedly. Russ Stanley, a man in a position to solve all of Bob's problems.
就在这时，鲍勃躲着乔·克洛克盖瑟，乔·克洛克盖瑟躲着卫生部门，协会的第三名成员意外去世了。拉斯·斯坦利，一个有能力解决鲍勃所有问题的人。
Russ Stanley used to call me at home every night and drive me nuts on the telephone for an hour, sometimes two hours-- I couldn't get rid of him-- telling me about every little thing that happened everywhere in the country about cryonics. To him, there was nothing else in life but cryonics and assuring me always that when he died, the society would be in good, good shape.
拉斯·斯坦利过去每晚都给我打家里电话，在电话里纠缠我一个小时，有时两个小时——我甩不掉他——告诉我全国各地发生的关于人体冷冻术的每一件小事。对他来说，生活中除了人体冷冻术没有别的，并总是向我保证，当他去世时，协会将会处于非常非常好的状态。
Russ used to always say, I am loaded. I own my own house. So I expected him to leave a couple hundred thousand dollars or something.
拉斯总是说，我很有钱。我有自己的房子。所以我期待他留下几十万美元或者之类的钱。
But had he left that much money?
但他留下了那么多钱吗？
He left his money to his next door neighbor, who was his ex-lover, a Mr. Coco. Mr. Coco hated cryonics. So he called me about three or four days after we had Russ in dry-- we put him in the container, too. So now we got three people in this dry ice container. It was big. I couldn't put anymore in there, but I figured, well, this was going to save the day. But Mr. Coco said, Russ Stanley directed me to give the Cryonics Society $5,000 now and $5,000 in three months.
他把钱留给了他的邻居，也就是他的前情人，可可先生。可可先生讨厌人体冷冻术。所以他在我们把拉斯放进干冰里——我们也把他放进了容器里——三四天后给我打电话。所以现在我们那个干冰容器里有三个人了。它很大。我不能再往里面放了，但我心想，好吧，这能解决问题。但可可先生说，拉斯·斯坦利指示我给你人体冷冻协会5000美元，三个月后再给5000美元。
It was enough money, at least, to solve Bob's most pressing problem-- to get a legal place to store the frozen bodies he was keeping in the garage. So he bought a plot of land and built a vault in a cemetery in Chatsworth, 30 miles north of LA. A 15x20 room dug like a bunker into a gently sloping hillside. Now all he needed were stainless steel capsules to hold the bodies into perpetuity.
至少有足够的钱来解决鲍勃最紧迫的问题——找一个合法的地方来存放他一直保存在车库里的冰冻尸体。于是他在洛杉矶以北30英里的查茨沃斯的一个墓地买了一块地，建了一个地下室。一个15x20的房间，像掩体一样挖进缓坡的山坡里。现在他唯一需要的就是不锈钢胶囊来永远保存尸体。
But as luck would have it, we got a call from Mrs. Bowers.
但正如运气所说，我们接到了鲍尔斯夫人的电话。
Mrs. Marie Bowers was a housewife from Detroit. A few years back her father had died, and she'd arranged to have him frozen by Ed Hope, the same guy who was storing Dr. Bedford in Phoenix, Arizona. Her father had spent a year and a half there in a one-man capsule the size of a standard water heater. Now, as it turned out, Marie was in a fix of her own.
玛丽·鲍尔斯夫人是底特律的一位家庭主妇。几年前她父亲去世了，她安排让艾德·霍普将他冷冻起来，就是那个在亚利桑那州凤凰城存放贝德福德博士的人。她父亲在那里一个热水器大小的单人胶囊里呆了一年半。现在，原来，玛丽自己也陷入了困境。
She couldn't pay the storage that Ed Hope was charging. She couldn't pay the liquid nitrogen. And she says, I owe him $1,500. And her exact words, she says, "He threatened to kick the effin' capsule out into the street." So she called me, and I went, wait. Well, hmm. Boy. If I could put a couple of people in that capsule, if I could get them all in there-- I didn't know if four people would fit in one capsule-- boy, would that solve my problem. And that would solve her problem.
她付不起艾德·霍普收取的存储费。她付不起液氮的钱。她说，我欠他1500美元。她原话是这么说的，“他威胁要把那个该死的胶囊踢到街上去。”所以她打电话给我，我就想，等等。嗯，哎。天哪。如果我能把几个人放进那个胶囊里，如果我能把他们都塞进去——我不知道四个人能不能塞进一个胶囊——天哪，那不就能解决我的问题了吗？那也能解决她的问题。
And again, that's probably the only thing that I am somewhat ashamed about-- that I didn't tell her that I was going to put three more people in there.
而且再说一次，这可能是我唯一感到有点羞愧的事情——我没告诉她我要把另外三个人放进去。
Why didn't you tell her?
你为什么不告诉她？
I don't know. Probably fear.
我不知道。可能是害怕。
Were you afraid-- was there part of you that was nervous if you did tell her that she might not go for it?
你害怕吗——有没有一部分你很紧张，如果你告诉她，她可能不会同意？
I wasn't worried about that because she had no alternative. She had nowhere else to go.
我不担心那个，因为她没有其他选择。她无处可去。
So why not tell her? What's the risk?
所以为什么不告诉她？风险是什么？
Well, I didn't think it was necessary to burden her with that big complex problem of her dad being coupled with other people. It might have been a problem for her. I don't know. Maybe it wouldn't have been.
嗯，我不觉得有必要用她父亲与其他人绑定在一起的这个大而复杂的问题去给增加她的负担。这对她来说可能是一个问题。我不知道。也许不会是。
The capsule arrived at the mortuary in Buena Park in the spring of 1969, and Bob was there to greet it. A cryonic container is basically a giant thermos, one steel tube inside another with a vacuum in between. So long as you added liquid nitrogen once every few months, the tank stayed really cold.
胶囊在1969年春天到达了布埃纳帕克的殡仪馆，鲍勃在那里迎接它。人体冷冻容器基本上就是一个巨大的保温瓶，一个钢管套在另一个钢管里，中间是真空的。只要你每隔几个月加一次液氮，罐子就会保持非常冷。
These containers weren't designed to be open and shut again, so when the time came to add the extra bodies, Bob had to improvise. He drained the liquid nitrogen and had a welder open the capsule with a blowtorch. They spent most of the night unsealing the tank and arranging the bodies, which they wrapped head to toe in Mylar. Joe Klockgether was there, too.
这些容器不是设计用来反复开关的，所以当需要增加额外尸体的时候，鲍勃不得不临时应变。他排干了液氮，并让一名焊接工用喷灯打开了胶囊。他们花了大部分时间密封罐子，并安排尸体，他们用聚酯薄膜把尸体从头到脚包裹起来。乔·克洛克盖瑟也在场。
Here again, I'm just kind of helping them because it's here. And I'm curious, too. Anybody would be curious just to see.
在这里，我只是帮他们个忙，因为东西就在这儿。而且我也很好奇。任何人都会好奇去看一看。
I was feeling excited and nervous because the question was, would we be able to orchestrate the arrangement of these bodies inside that container successfully?
我感到既兴奋又紧张，因为问题是，我们能成功地安排这些尸体在容器里吗？
Well, first of all, you have to see how much room was in there. Yeah, just to move-- because of the configuration of the container. Well, it was round, of course. But just to get it to fit right, you know? These people were frozen. And when they were frozen, it could have been maybe an elbow out, so you might have to turn them another way to get the other one to slide beside them. I mean, oh, it was cramped. Yeah, it was cramped.
嗯，首先，你得看看里面有多大空间。是的，仅仅是为了移动——因为容器的结构。嗯，当然它是圆的。但只是为了让它合适，你知道吗？这些人是被冷冻的。当他们被冷冻时，可能有一只胳膊伸出来，所以你可能得换个方向，让另一个人从旁边滑进去。我是说，噢，这很拥挤。是的，太挤了。
I had to have gloves on because the body is like steel. And 300 degrees below zero, it's like holding a pot that's 300 degrees above zero. It's just, you can't do it. And it took probably a couple of hours to get them so that everyone was comfortably arranged.
我不得不戴上手套，因为身体就像钢一样。在零下300度，就像拿着一个300度的锅一样。就是，你做不到。花了大概几个小时才把它们安顿好，让每个人都舒适地排列。
Then they sealed the container back up. It was that simple. Bob told two confidants about the welder and the four bodies in the tank. Otherwise, he kept it a secret. He'd done what he felt he had to do. And for the moment, what he felt was relief. He'd steered the car back onto the road, secured a working capsule for the four people in his care and a legal vault to keep it in. From here on out, he'd be practical and businesslike. No more soft-hearted exceptions. No more pro bono freezings.
然后他们把容器重新密封起来。就这么简单。鲍勃告诉了两位知己关于焊接工和罐子里的四具尸体的事。除此之外，他保密了。他做了他觉得必须做的事情。而在那一刻，他感到的是解脱。他把车又开回了正轨，为他照顾的四个人找到了一个功能正常的胶囊，以及一个合法的地下室来保存它。从现在开始，他要讲究实际，公事公办。不再有心软的例外。不再有免费的冷冻。
But the capsule Bob had pinned his hopes on needed round-the-clock attention. When you're dealing with equipment that's supposed to last hundreds of years, you want the kind of engineering that goes into building a space capsule. This was not that.
但鲍勃寄予希望的那个胶囊需要24小时的全天候关注。当你处理预计要持续数百年的设备时，你会想要那种建造太空舱的工程技术。这可不是那种。
We had to keep a pump, an electronic pump, pulling the vacuum 24 hours a day, seven days a week. At Chatsworth, the temperatures got up to over 100, 110 sometimes. And that was death to these vacuum pumps. They couldn't take that heat. The pumps would burn out, need to be replaced. Then it just got worse and worse and worse. I was there, I would say, virtually every day.
我们必须保持一台泵，一台电子泵，一天24小时，一周7天不停地抽取真空。在查茨沃斯，气温有时会升到100度、110度以上。这对这些真空泵来说简直是死刑。它们受不了那种热。泵会烧坏，需要更换。然后情况变得越来越糟。我几乎每天都在那儿。
After Bob opened up the tank, it was never quite the same. The vacuum was shot, and the liquid nitrogen would boil away to nothing. Bob was constantly refilling the tank with coolant at a few hundred bucks a pop. Sometimes he wrote checks from his personal bank account. Sometimes the checks would bounce. Meanwhile, he was flying around the country, giving lectures, showing off artist's renderings of the futuristic cryonics facility he planned to build, appearing on radio and TV talk shows-- Regis Philbin, Phil Donahue.
鲍勃打开罐子后，情况就再也没恢复原样。真空失效了，液氮会沸腾殆尽。鲍勃不断地花几百美元给罐子补充冷却剂。有时他开的是个人银行账户的支票。有时支票会退票。与此同时，他飞往全国各地，发表讲座，炫耀他计划建造的未来派人体冷冻设施的艺术效果图，出现在广播和电视脱口秀节目中——雷吉斯·菲尔宾、菲尔·多纳胡。
What exactly is the perfusion process?
灌注过程到底是什么？
The perfusion process--
灌注过程——
Here he is on a local LA newscast.
这是他在当地洛杉矶新闻节目中的表现。
--protecting the patient biologically for the cold temperatures that he is going to be exposed to.
——在生物学上保护病人，使其能够应对即将暴露的低温环境。
You ever seen or heard the movie Three Faces of Eve? This is the Two Faces of Bob Nelson. The dual role of my life was to on the one hand, be a spokesman for cryonics, and then on the other hand was my nightmare responsibility of keeping this antique capsule running.
你看过或者听说过电影《三面夏娃》吗？这就是鲍勃·尼尔森的两面。我生活中的双重角色一方面是人体冷冻术的代言人，另一方面是我维护这个古董胶囊的噩梦责任。
The publicity worked. It attracted new people to be frozen, some of them with the ability to pay for it. Then, in July of 1971, Bob got a call from a Canadian man named Guy, the father of a seven-year-old girl dying of a rare kidney cancer.
宣传起作用了。它吸引了新人来被冷冻，其中一些人有支付能力。然后，在1971年7月，鲍勃接到了一个名叫盖伊的加拿大男子的电话，他是一个死于罕见肾癌的7岁女孩的父亲。
One day, everything was fine. The next day, doctors were telling him his child had weeks to live. The way Guy saw it, it didn't matter if cryonics was a long shot. Bob Nelson presented the only slim hope his daughter had left. Guy didn't have a lot of money, but he managed to fly Genevieve to California, where he got her admitted to a children's hospital. Bob remembers meeting her there.
有一天，一切都很好。第二天，医生告诉他他的孩子只剩下几周的生命了。在盖伊看来，人体冷冻术是不是遥不可及并不重要。鲍勃·尼尔森提出了他女儿仅存的一线希望。盖伊没有多少钱，但他设法把吉纳维芙飞到了加州，让她住进了一家儿童医院。鲍勃记得在那里见到了她。
She was sitting on the bed, and her dad was with her. And she always had the expression of-- it was so sad. So, so sad. Because she knew how sick she was. She knew she was dying, and she didn't want to.
她坐在床上，她父亲陪着她。她总是带着那种表情——非常悲伤。非常，非常悲伤。因为她知道自己病得多重。她知道自己快要死了，但她不想。
Did her parents talk to her about the idea of being frozen?
她的父母和她谈过被冷冻的想法吗？
Yes, they did. And she didn't seem to have much of an opinion one way or the other. Because it still meant that she had to die. And she didn't want to leave her sisters and her family. She wanted to go back to school.
是的，他们谈过了。她对这事儿没什么特别的意见。因为这意味着她依然得死。她不想离开她的姐妹和家人。她想回到学校。
Bob knew he shouldn't be performing another free suspension, but he couldn't help it. He had a daughter of his own just a couple of years older. He went to see Genevieve a lot. One day, she made a request.
鲍勃知道他不应该再进行一次冷冻悬浮了，但他无法拒绝。他自己也有一个只比她大几岁的女儿。他经常去见吉纳维芙。有一天，她提出了一个要求。
Genevieve only spoke French, so the mother would interpret. And her mom said, Mr. Nelson, Genevieve wants to ask you a question. So I said, what? And she said, did I know where Disneyland was? And I said, yes, I do. Matter of fact, my buddy Donald Duck and Mickey Mouse work there. And so she told Genevieve that, and Genevieve, ooh-- like that.
吉纳维芙只说法语，所以母亲会翻译。她妈妈说，尼尔森先生，吉纳维芙想问你一个问题。所以我说，什么？她说，我知道迪士尼乐园在哪里吗？我说，是的，我知道。事实上，我的伙伴唐老鸭和米老鼠就在那儿工作。所以她告诉了吉纳维芙，吉纳维芙，噢——就是那样。
And I said to her mom, why is-- she said, the doctor said that it'd be OK for her to go because sitting here is not good for her. I said, I can't believe it. So I said, tell Genevieve, could she be ready to go to Disneyland tomorrow morning?
我对她妈妈说，为什么——她说，医生说她去一趟是可以的，因为坐在这里对她没好处。我说，我简直不敢相信。所以我说，告诉吉纳维芙，她明天早上能准备好去迪士尼乐园吗？
We went the next morning and picked up Genevieve and drove to Disneyland. And we got her in a wheelchair and drove her, pushed her around. And she got in the tea cup and the different things with my young daughter. And then, at one point, she was in one of these little kid-- turtle game, I think it was. And her mom says, Mr. Nelson, Genevieve wants to ask you another question. And I said, sure, what would that be? And she said, would I learn French, so that she could talk to me? And I said, I will do that just for you.
我们第二天早上接到了吉纳维芙，驱车前往迪士尼乐园。我们让她坐在轮椅里，推着她到处走。她和我的小女儿一起坐了茶杯和其他游乐设施。然后，在某个时候，她坐在一个小孩子的——我想是乌龟游戏里。她妈妈说，尼尔森先生，吉纳维芙想再问你一个问题。我说，当然，是什么？她说，我能学法语吗，这样她就能和我说话了？我说，我会为你学法语的。
For a little while, it looked like Genevieve was improving. Then one morning, Bob was back at the hospital.
有一阵子，看起来吉纳维芙在好转。然后一天早上，鲍勃又回到了医院。
Guy was sitting on the bed, and he was holding her. And oh, I stopped. I knew this was a sacred moment. And so he looked up, and he said, get the nurse. I think Genevieve has passed. And so I got the nurse, and sure enough, she had passed.
盖伊坐在床上，抱着她。噢，我停住了。我知道这是一个神圣的时刻。他抬头看着，说，快叫护士。我想吉纳维芙已经去世了。所以我叫了护士，果不其然，她已经去世了。
So he put her back on the bed, and then it was all business. It was critically important to get her temperature down. That's the most important thing about a cryonic suspension is that once the heart stops, the temperature has got to drop. Nothing is more important than that.
所以他把她放回床上，然后一切就都是公事了。降低她的体温至关重要。人体冷冻悬浮最重要的事情就是一旦心脏停止跳动，体温就必须降下来。没有什么比这更重要的了。
They packed her in ice, put her in what's called a body bag. It's a plastic bag that they put ice on the bottom. And then they lay her on that, and then totally cover her body with ice, and put her on a gurney, and put her in the hearse. So within an hour and a half, she was on the mortuary table, receiving a perfusion and having her temperature further lowered.
他们用冰把她包裹起来，装进所谓的尸袋里。那是一个塑料袋，他们在底部铺上冰。然后把她放在上面，接着用冰完全覆盖她的身体，把她放在担架上，送进灵车。所以在一个半小时内，她就在殡仪馆的桌子上了，接受灌注并进一步降低体温。
According to Bob, Guy hoped to raise $10,000 to pay for a capsule, but he just couldn't manage. He had a pile of medical bills and two other kids to worry about. So Bob found himself back in the same fix-- short on funds with a couple of bodies in temporary dry ice storage. He did the only thing he knew how to do.
根据鲍勃的说法，盖伊希望筹集1万美元来支付胶囊的费用，但他实在做不到。他有一堆医疗账单，还有两个孩子要照顾。所以鲍勃发现自己又陷入了同样的困境——资金短缺，还有几具尸体在临时的干冰存储中。他做了他唯一知道该怎么做的事情。
In 1972, Bob arranged to take custody of a cryonics patient named Steven Mandell, who'd been frozen and sealed in a capsule in New York. It was the Marie Bowers capsule all over again. He opened it up, added Genevieve and another woman he'd frozen, Mildred Harris, and welded it shut again.
1972年，鲍勃安排收容了一名名叫史蒂文·曼德尔的人体冷冻病人，他被冷冻并密封在纽约的一个胶囊里。这简直是玛丽·鲍尔斯胶囊事件的重演。他把它打开，加入了吉纳维芙和另一名他冷冻的女性米尔德里德·哈里斯，然后再次焊死。
By now, the first capsule was breaking down more or less constantly. And Bob had hit a wall. The way he describes it, it's as if he was the captain of a sinking ship, throwing cargo over the side to stay afloat. He couldn't save them all. And so he'd come to a decision. He would let the first capsule fail. This much is clear. He kept it a secret.
到现在，第一个胶囊几乎一直在损坏。鲍勃撞到了墙上。他形容这种方式，就好像他是沉船的船长，把货物扔过船舷以保持浮力。他救不了所有人。于是他做了一个决定。他会让第一个胶囊失效。这一点很清楚。他保密了。
The second capsule was practically as bad as the first, constantly malfunctioning, boiling off liquid nitrogen. But Bob kept it going. Then a few years later, he had to leave town for a week. He paid a groundskeeper $100 to babysit the capsule, and the pump broke. And when the groundskeeper called a company to fix it, they never showed.
第二个胶囊几乎和第一个一样糟糕，不断发生故障，液氮沸腾殆尽。但鲍勃一直坚持着。然后几年后，他不得不出城一周。他付给一名园丁100美元看管胶囊，泵坏了。当园丁打电话给一家公司维修时，他们根本没露面。
I came back, drove up to the vault, looked at the capsule. There's a nozzle that comes out of the capsule that has steam, visible, because the liquid nitrogen is evaporating away. And when I drove up and I looked, that steam wasn't there. So I just didn't want to acknowledge what that meant. But the test was to go and touch that pipe, and if it was cold, then there was some hope. That meant that it was still cold inside.
我回来了，开车到地下室，看了一眼胶囊。胶囊里冒出一个喷嘴，有蒸汽，显而易见的，因为液氮正在蒸发。当我开车过来观察时，没有蒸汽。我只是不想承认这意味着什么。但测试方法是去摸一下那根管子，如果它是凉的，那么还有希望。这意味着里面还是冷的。
And then, going through my mind, what if it's hot? What if those bodies have decomposed? So I walk up to the capsule. I put my finger on it. And it was like touching a hot frying pan. It was the most painful, emotional experience of my life. I had failed that little girl. I promised her dad. And she was gone.
然后，我脑子里闪过，如果它是热的呢？如果那些尸体已经分解了呢？所以我走向胶囊。我把手指放在上面。感觉就像摸到一个热油锅。这是我一生中最痛苦、最情绪化的经历。我辜负了那个小女孩。我答应过她父亲。她走了。
Bob says he immediately flew to Montreal to tell Genevieve's father in person.
鲍勃说他立即飞往蒙特利尔亲自告诉吉纳维芙的父亲。
In Montreal, though, is where the story really starts to get interesting. And that's coming up in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
然而，在蒙特利尔，故事才真正开始变得有趣。从芝加哥公共广播电台，我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life, I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our show, we choose a theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, Mistakes Were Made. Sam Shaw's story about Bob Nelson continues. Bob has just discovered that his second freezing capsule has failed. Liquid nitrogen has leaked out. And he says the first person that he went to tell was the little girl, Genevieve's father.
这是《这一美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，我们都会选择一个主题，带来关于该主题的不同故事。今天的节目，“犯了错”。萨姆·肖关于鲍勃·尼尔森的故事继续。鲍勃刚刚发现他的第二个冷冻胶囊失效了。液氮泄漏了。他说他去告诉的第一个人就是那个小女孩吉纳维芙的父亲。
So he met me at the airport in a little snack shop, coffee shop. He was right in my face instantly. What happened? And I tried to tell him as gently as I could. Then when he pressed me, how many days? How long? I said, I don't know. Three, four, five? I don't know.
所以在机场的一个小零食店，咖啡店，他遇到了我。他立刻就面对面跟我说了。发生了什么事？我尽量温和地告诉他。然后当他逼问我时，多少天？多长时间？我说，我不知道。三、四、五天？我不知道。
And what he said just totally blew me away. He said, well, I guess we'll just have to start it up again and continue on. And I said, OK. I think I should have fought it out with him right there, but I didn't. I turned around and walked away. Cowardly, I think. He was shook. He left, and I could see his face was red. He was upset.
而他所说的完全让我震惊。他说，嗯，我想我们就只能重新开始，继续下去。我说，好的。我觉得我应该当场就和他争论一番，但我没有。我转身走开了。我认为这很懦弱。他被震撼了。他离开了，我能看到他的脸是红的。他很沮丧。
Next, Bob says he flew to see Terry Harris, whose mother, Mildred Harris, was in the second capsule with Genevieve and whose father, Gaylord, was also in the vault.
接下来，鲍勃说他飞去见了特里·哈里斯，他的母亲米尔德里德·哈里斯和吉纳维芙在第二个胶囊里，他的父亲盖洛德也在地下室里。
And he met me at the airport and introduced me to his wife. I told him what happened. And he just said, oh. Well, did you fill it up again? I said, yeah. So he essentially said the same thing that Guy said.
他在机场接我，向我介绍了他的妻子。我告诉了他发生的事情。他只是说，哦。嗯，你又加满了吗？我说，是的。所以他基本上说了盖伊说的一样的话。
Did he understand what it meant?
他明白这意味着什么吗？
It's almost like he didn't care. I mean, no, no, no, let me take that back. Not that he didn't care-- no, it was more like, oh, well. Far enough into the future, they'll be able to fix that, too.
几乎就像他不在乎。我是说，不、不、不，让我收回那句话。不是说他不在乎——不，更像是，噢，好吧。在遥远的未来，他们也能修好那个的。
A few days after Bob told me a story, I talked on the phone with Genevieve's father, Guy. He was polite, and I must say, very patient with my questions. But he didn't want to be interviewed on the radio. The memory of Genevieve's death and suspension was just too painful. He said a little ruefully that the whole idea of cryonics might be a moot point, anyway, given the state of the world. The way things were going, even if the science panned out, there might not be a future to return to.
鲍勃告诉我这个故事几天后，我和吉纳维芙的父亲盖伊通了电话。他很有礼貌，我必须说，对我的提问非常有耐心。但他不想在广播中接受采访。关于吉纳维芙死亡和悬浮的记忆太痛苦了。他有点懊悔地说，鉴于世界的现状，人体冷冻术的整个想法本身可能就是一个毫无意义的问题。事情的发展方式是，即使科学研究成功了，未来可能也没有可以回归的地方。
And then he told me something else. That meeting at the airport Bob remembered so vividly, Guy said it never happened. So next, I contacted Terry Harris, and I told him Bob's version of what transpired.
然后他告诉我另一件事。鲍勃记得那么生动的那次机场会议，盖伊说那根本没发生过。所以接下来，我联系了特里·哈里斯，并告诉了他鲍勃关于所发生事情的版本。
Terry, as you know, Bob tells this very detailed story about coming to tell you that the capsule--
特里，如你所知，鲍勃讲了一个非常详细的故事，说他来告诉你那个胶囊——
Terry says Bob never told him about the failure of the capsule. He had to hear about it from an article in the California newspaper that his aunt sent him in Des Moines.
特里说鲍勃从来没告诉过他胶囊失效的事。他是从他姨妈寄给他的一篇加州报纸文章中听说的。
They said in the article that the machinery had broken down. And it was just incredulous. I just couldn't believe it. So I called Bob, and he assured me that everything was fine. And the paper was just trying to generate a sensational readership. And so I never saw him. I just talked to him on the phone at that point.
文章里说机器坏了。这简直让人难以置信。我简直不敢相信。所以我给鲍勃打了电话，他向我保证一切都好。报纸只是为了制造轰动效应以吸引读者。所以我也没见过他。那时我只是在电话里跟他谈过。
Right. So there was never a time when Bob flew out and met with you at the airport?
对。所以从来没有鲍勃飞过来在机场和你见面的事情？
No. That would have been the right and honorable thing to do. And I wish it had occurred. But it's just not accurate.
没有。那本来是正确且体面的做法。我希望这发生过。但这根本不准确。
Terry Harris was in his early 20s when he met Bob Nelson. He'd lost both his parents in a span of three months. And cryonics had seemed like this great thing he could give them in return. He sometimes imagined what it would be like when they were all reunited as a family in some distant, dreamlike future. It gave him hope. And then everything had gone so wrong.
特里·哈里斯在遇到鲍勃·尼尔森时才20出头。他在三个月内失去了双亲。而人体冷冻术似乎是他可以给他们的很棒的回馈。他有时会想象当他们一家人在某个遥远、梦幻的未来团聚时会是什么样子。这给了他希望。然后一切都出错得太离谱了。
So I called Bob, and I told him about my conversations with Guy and Terry. He was shocked, and he stuck to his story. Later that day, he sent me a long pained email, calling the situation a heart-wrenching predicament. He called Terry Harris a liar. But Guy was another matter. Bob said he was devastated that Guy didn't remember their talk in the Montreal airport. He wondered if it was possible that Guy had repressed the memory.
所以我打了给鲍勃，告诉了他我和盖伊以及特里的谈话。他很震惊，并坚持自己的故事。那天晚些时候，他发给我一封长长的痛苦邮件，称这种情况是一个令人心碎的困境。他称特里·哈里斯是个骗子。但盖伊又是另一回事。鲍勃说，盖伊不记得他们在蒙特利尔机场的谈话，这让他崩溃了。他怀疑盖伊是否可能压抑了这段记忆。
Then I spoke to him a few days later, and he offered this take.
然后我几天后和他谈了，他提出了这种看法。
I would say this about that, that if Guy said that I never came to the airport in Montreal, then he's right. I have to concede that it's possible that what happened-- because I've been mulling this over for the past few days. It's possible what I'm remembering is going through this scenario with him over the phone.
关于这一点，我想说，如果盖伊说我从来没去过蒙特利尔机场，那他是对的。我必须承认，发生的事情可能是这样——因为我过去几天一直在反复琢磨。我记得发生的可能是通过电话和他经历了这一切。
Yeah. I mean, when you talked about it, it sounded so vivid. You remember it being in a sandwich shop and--
是的。我是说，当你谈论它时，听起来太生动了。你记得是在一家三明治店——
Well, in my mind, I must have been over it 1,000 times. What it was going to be like to face him, to talk to him. And it was just the horror of my life because it just-- so anyway, I have to agree that most likely, I didn't go to Montreal.
嗯，在我脑海里，我一定反复过1000次。面对他，和他交谈会是什么样子。那是我一生中的噩梦，因为它就是——所以总之，我不得不承认，我最有可能没去过蒙特利尔。
To be clear, Guy says he never heard from Bob at all-- no visit, no phone call, nothing.
明确一点，盖伊说他根本没收到过鲍勃的任何消息——没有访问，没有电话，什么都没有。
I'm just wondering if, when you look at that memory, that seems like it was a faulty memory, if it gives you any pause and makes you wonder whether there are other parts of this set of memories that you have that may also not be totally trustworthy.
我只是想知道，当你看着那段记忆，如果它看起来是一段错误的记忆，它是否会让你停顿一下，让你怀疑你拥有的这组记忆中是否有其他部分可能也不是完全可信的。
Other parts? Such as?
其他部分？比如？
Well, such as Terry Harris.
嗯，比如特里·哈里斯。
No. Sam, I'm never going to budge one speck from that. You need to believe what you need to believe, Sam. I'm only telling you that I'm telling you what I-- and there would be no reason for me to make up that I went to see Terry Harris and them. That's not part of the story. That isn't important to my story.
不。萨姆，我绝不会在那件事上挪动半分。你需要相信你所需要相信的，萨姆。我只是告诉你我在告诉你什么——而且我没理由捏造我去看过特里·哈里斯他们。那不是故事的一部分。那对我的故事不重要。
But don't you think that there might be a reason why it would be important for you to believe that you went out and had those conversations with them face to face?
但你不认为可能有某种原因让你认为你出去并面对面地和他们进行了那些谈话是很重要的吗？
How do you defend yourself-- I don't know. How do you defend yourself against something that's not true? I don't know.
你如何为自己辩护——我不知道。你如何为不真实的事情为自己辩护？我不知道。
What's clear is that Bob's convinced he did right by Terry and Guy, and Terry and Guy are equally convinced that he didn't. If it sounds like Bob is harder on Terry than he is on Guy, there's one more thing you have to understand. When the truth about the two failed capsules and the nine bodies in the vault finally came to light, when all those hard decisions Bob had made on the fly became sound bites on the 10 o'clock news, there wasn't just a public reckoning. There was a trial.
显而易见的是，鲍勃深信他善待了特里和盖伊，而特里和盖伊同样深信他没有。如果鲍勃听起来对特里比对盖伊更严厉，你还需要了解一件事。当两个失效的胶囊和地下室里九具尸体的真相终于曝光，当所有鲍勃在匆忙中做出的艰难决定变成10点新闻里的声音片段时，不仅仅是有公众清算。还有一场审判。
Terry and his brother were two of the plaintiffs, and they won to the tune of $800,000. The half they actually collected came out of mortician Joe Klockgether's malpractice insurance.
特里和他的兄弟是原告中的两个，他们赢得了80万美元的赔偿。他们实际拿到的一半钱来自殡葬师乔·克洛克盖瑟的医疗事故保险。
In 1979, the Harris brothers flew out to California to meet an attorney who led them to the vault at Chatsworth, along with a local TV news team. By that point, Bob had washed his hands of the Cryonics Society. He was dead broke, and his marriage had fallen apart. And he just walked away. And for the first time, Terry saw the reality of his parents' situation with his own eyes.
1979年，哈里斯兄弟飞往加州，见了一位律师，律师带领他们前往查茨沃斯的地下室，还有一队当地电视新闻组。那时，鲍勃已经甩手不管人体冷冻协会了。他身无分文，婚姻破裂。他直接走了。这是特里第一次亲眼看到他父母处境的现实。
Well, the door in the facility was made of steel. And it was then chained and padlocked closed. The chain was rusty, and there was grass growing around that door where, before, it wasn't. And our attorney brought a pair of bolt cutters, and removed that lock and chain, and slid the door back. And we went down, and you could just see that there was a piece of equipment here and there, and the capsule lid open.
嗯，设施里的门是用钢做的。那时候它是用链条和挂锁锁住的。链条生锈了，门周围长满了草，之前那儿没长草。我们的律师拿了一把断线钳，去掉了锁和链条，把门滑开。我们下去了，你只能看到这里有一件设备，那里有一件，胶囊盖子开着。
And it was unbearable, just unbearable. And I was just-- I was just numb. Just numb. Well, I couldn't look inside that capsule, but I just backed away when I realized that there were just remains inside. We brought flowers. And so we laid them there by the capsule, and then I just went up the stairs and left.
简直难以承受，简直难以承受。我只是——我当时麻木了。只是麻木。嗯，我没法看那个胶囊里面，但我意识到里面只是遗骸时，我就退缩了。我们带了花。所以我们把花放在胶囊旁边，然后我就上了楼梯离开了。
I felt guilty because I should have been there night and day, which, of course, isn't very realistic. But at the time, I felt very guilty.
我感到内疚，因为我应该昼夜待在那儿，这当然不太现实。但在当时，我感到非常内疚。
Here's the entrance. This is the management office over here. I mean, it looks identical to the day that I was here 40 years ago. This little shack was here. This chapel was exactly the same.
这是入口。这是这边的管理办公室。我是说，它看起来和40年前我在那儿的那天一模一样。这个小棚屋就在这儿。这个礼拜堂也是一模一样的。
Bob and I drove out the cemetery in Chatsworth on a sunny afternoon in March. We spent about an hour wandering the grounds, Bob pointing out landmarks and citing names and dates like a breezy tour guide. He said it felt good to be back.
三月的一个阳光明媚的下午，我和鲍勃开车去了查茨沃斯的墓地。我们花了大约一个小时在场地里徘徊，鲍勃像一个轻快的导游一样指点着地标，列举着名字和日期。他说回来感觉真好。
Oakwood is a really beautiful spot, a rolling park surrounded by jagged sandstone hilltops. Fred Astaire and Ginger Rogers are buried there. And the cemetery staff will point you to the grave sites of a half dozen lesser stars. But none of the groundskeepers we talked to had ever heard of a cryonics facility there. And really, it's no surprise. Where the vault used to be, there's just an empty swath of grass-- no padlocked opening, no monument or plaque.
奥克伍德是一个非常美丽的地方，一个被锯齿状砂岩山顶环绕的起伏公园。弗雷德·阿斯泰尔和琴吉·罗杰斯就葬在那里。墓地工作人员会为你指明半打次要明星的墓地。但我们交谈过的园丁中没有人听说过那里有个什么人体冷冻设施。真的，这并不奇怪。以前地下室所在的地方，现在只是一片空旷的草地——没有加锁的开口，没有纪念碑或牌匾。
See where the ground rises up over here? This was where the vault is. See where these-- they've put two benches right here.
看到这边地面隆起的地方了吗？这就是地下室所在的地方。看到这些——他们在这里放了两张长凳。
Bob says all but two of the people he froze are still sealed in the vault, now covered over with sod. But the cemetery management tells a different story. They say the bodies were all disinterred years ago, which leaves one final question. Again, Terry Harris.
鲍勃说他冷冻的人中除两人外仍然密封在地下室里，现在上面铺着草皮。但墓地管理处却有不同的说法。他们说尸体多年前都被挖掘出来了，这就留下了一个最终的问题。再说一次，特里·哈里斯。
I have no idea where my parents are.
我根本不知道我父母在哪儿。
You have no idea where they're buried now?
你根本不知道他们现在埋在哪儿？
No. No. The management of the cemetery said, well, they're gone. And I said, well, what do you mean gone? And he said, well, one day, a big pickup truck came up there and disinterred them, and took them away. And he said he didn't have any legal permit to do that. They didn't provide anything. Now, doesn't that sound outlandish to you?
不。不。墓地管理处说，嗯，他们没了。我说，嗯，什么叫没了？他说，嗯，有一天，一辆大皮卡车来到那里，把他们挖出来，带走了。他说他没有法律许可那样做。他们没提供任何东西。现在，这听起来不是很荒唐吗？
This is where all Bob's secrets and lies about the bodies finally led-- to Terry Harris making phone calls, writing letters, combing through legal documents. Somewhere he figured there had to be a record-- a clue that would tell him what had become of his parents. He's never found it.
这就是鲍勃关于尸体的所有秘密和谎言最终导致的后果——特里·哈里斯不断打电话、写信、梳理法律文件。他想，某个地方肯定有记录——一条线索告诉他父母变成了什么样。他从未找到。
Cryonics carried on without Bob Nelson. And all these years later, when people in the field tell Bob's story, they call it the Chatsworth disaster. On cryonics discussion boards, he's been labeled a murderer-- though, of course, all the people he supposedly killed were dead to begin with. When Bob talks about those years, he says he's gotten a bad rap. He genuinely seems to feel bad about failing Genevieve and her family, and for dragging the mortician, Joe Klockgether, through the trial.
人体冷冻术在没有鲍勃·尼尔森的情况下继续进行。多年以后，当该领域的人讲述鲍勃的故事时，他们称之为查茨沃斯灾难。在人体冷冻术讨论版上，他被贴上了谋杀犯的标签——尽管当然，他所谓的杀害的所有人本来就已经死了。当鲍勃谈到那些年时，他说他背了黑锅。他确实表现出为辜负了吉纳维芙和她的家人而感到抱歉，也为拖累了殡葬师乔·克洛克盖瑟参加审判而感到抱歉。
But just as emphatically, he'll tell you that his main mistake was caring too much. That the secrets he kept were necessary to keep the project going. And above all, that the people he froze had donated their bodies under the Anatomical Gift Act.
但同样强调的是，他会告诉你，他最大的错误就是太在乎了。他守住的秘密是为了维持项目运转所必需的。最重要的是，他冷冻的人是根据《解剖捐赠法》捐赠了他们的身体。
Which meant that they donated their body to the Cryonics Society of California. And according to my attorney, we could grind them up for hamburger if that's what we wanted to do. We were given the right by the state of California to carry on research and do whatever we wanted in the perfection of suspended animation.
这意味着他们把身体捐给了加州人体冷冻协会。根据我的律师，如果那是我们想做的话，我们可以把他们磨成汉堡肉。加州政府给了我们权力进行研究，并在悬浮动画的完善中做我们想做的任何事。
And so we just felt that there's no need to be telling other people. I mean, I could have just locked that capsule, that vault up, and not told anybody that we'd stop putting liquid nitrogen in there. That probably could have gone on until today. You know? But at some point, I had to settle back down to reality.
所以我们觉得没必要告诉其他人。我是说，我本可以把那个胶囊、那个地下室锁起来，不告诉任何人我们停止往里面放液氮了。那可能一直持续到今天。你知道吗？但总有一天，我必须回到现实中来。
Bob says a lot depends on your perspective. If the science of cryonics pans out, it'll be possible to look at Genevieve, and Mildred Harris, and Helen Kline as casualties of progress-- or as Bob calls them, frozen heroes. Bob's not a rich guy, but he's managed to save $28,000 to pay for his own freezing at the Cryonics Institute in Michigan. He thinks his odds of reanimation are pretty good.
鲍勃说很多取决于你的视角。如果人体冷冻术的科学研究成功了，就有可能把吉纳维芙、米尔德里德·哈里斯和海伦·克莱恩视为进步的牺牲品——或者像鲍勃称呼她们的那样，冷冻的英雄。鲍勃不是有钱人，但他设法攒了2.8万美元来支付自己在密歇根州人体冷冻研究所的冷冻费用。他认为自己复活的几率相当不错。
And in the end, that's the thing that sustains him-- the hope that someday, in 50 years, or 100, or 1,000, he'll wake up in a world he barely recognizes. A world where Chatsworth wasn't a disaster, but the first imperfect battle in the war that saved us all.
最终，这就是支撑他的东西——希望在50年、100年或1000年后的某一天，他会在一个他几乎认不出来的世界中醒来。一个查茨沃斯不是灾难，而是拯救了我们所有人的战争中第一次不完美战斗的世界。
Sam Shaw-- his regular job, he writes for television. Bob Nelson published a memoir about his years in cryonics. It's called Freezing People is Not Easy.
萨姆·肖——他的日常工作是为电视写作。鲍勃·尼尔森出版了一本关于他从事人体冷冻术的回忆录。书名是《冷冻人并不容易》。
Today's show is a rerun, actually, from 2008. And years after we first ran this episode, Bob died. That was in June 2018. And as for his body, it took some time, but his family raised the money to honor his wishes. Bob is awaiting reanimation at the Cryonics Institute in Clinton Township, Michigan, alongside his hero, Robert Ettinger. His old friend and co-defendant, the mortician, Joe Klockgether, oversaw his suspension.
今天的节目，其实是一次2008年的重播。在我们首次播出这一集多年后，鲍勃去世了。那是在2018年6月。至于他的身体，花了点时间，但他的家人筹集了资金来尊重他的遗愿。鲍勃正在密歇根州克林顿镇的人体冷冻研究所等待复活，与他的英雄罗伯特·埃廷格在一起。他的老朋友兼共同被告，殡葬师乔·克洛克盖瑟监督了他的悬浮。
[MUSIC - FEIST, "SO SORRY"]
[音乐 - 菲斯特《如此抱歉》]
Act Two, You're Willing to Sacrifice Our Love. So one of our producers, Sean Cole-- when we came up with this idea to do an episode about people who were apologizing without fully apologizing, he pointed out this poem, which is basically that in a nutshell. In addition to making radio, Sean is a published poet.
第二幕，你愿意牺牲我们的爱。我们的制片人之一肖恩·科尔——当我们想出这个主意要制作一集关于那些没有完全道歉就进行道歉的人的节目时，他指出了这首诗，这基本上就是那种情况的缩影。除了制作广播节目，肖恩还是一位出版过的诗人。
So the poem's by William Carlos Williams. And it's a poem that's taught a lot in all sorts of poetry classes everywhere and, particularly, elementary schools, which is where I heard about it. And the way it was taught to me was that it was an actual note that William Carlos Williams left for his wife. And I always sort of imagined it sitting there on the kitchen table, waiting for her.
所以这首诗是威廉·卡洛斯·威廉斯写的。这是一首在各地各种诗歌课上经常教授的诗，尤其是小学，我就是在那儿听说的。老师教给我的方式是，这是一张威廉·卡洛斯·威廉斯留给妻子的真实纸条。我总是想象它放在餐桌上，等着她。
Right.
对。
And it's called, "This Is Just to Say." "I have eaten the plums that were in the ice box and which you were probably saving for breakfast. Forgive me. They were delicious, so sweet and so cold."
它叫《这只是要说》。“我吃了放在冰箱里的李子，那些你可能留着当早餐的。原谅我。它们太美味了，那么甜，那么冷。”
What's funny about the poem is that he never really apologizes.
这首诗有趣的地方在于他从不真正道歉。
He never apologizes. He says forgive me, which is kind of a command. And so I feel like it's like, oh, I ate the plums, and that was a bad thing. But I'm not sorry I did it.
他从不道歉。他说原谅我，那算是一种命令。所以我感觉它就像，噢，我吃了李子，那是一件坏事。但我并不为我做过的事感到抱歉。
It's interesting to me that it makes you mad.
这让我感到有趣的是，它让你生气。
The thing that really breaks my heart is that she was saving them. And when he says probably saving them for breakfast, he knew she was saving them for breakfast. There's no probably about it. They live together.
真正让我心碎的是她本来把它们存着。当他说可能留着当早餐时，他知道她是留着当早餐的。根本没有可能这一说。他们住在一起。
Now, this is a poem that is often imitated?
现在，这是一首经常被模仿的诗？
Imitated. Spoofed by many a poet. It's kind of become a game among poets to write a version of "This Is Just to Say." My favorite one is by a poet named Kenneth Koch.
模仿。被许多诗人戏仿。在诗人之间写一个《这只是要说》的版本已经成了一种游戏。我最喜欢的是一位名叫肯尼斯·科赫的诗人写的。
OK, let's hear him.
好的，让我们听听他的。
"I chopped down the house that you had been saving to live in next summer. I am sorry. But it was morning, and I had nothing to do. And its wooden beams were so inviting." "Last evening we went dancing, and I broke your leg. Forgive me. I was clumsy, and I wanted you here in the wards where I am the doctor."
“我砍倒了你留着明年夏天住的房子。我很抱歉。但那是早上，我无事可做。而且它的木梁太诱人了。”“昨晚我们去跳舞，我弄断了你的腿。原谅我。我笨手笨脚的，而且我想让你待在我当医生的病房里。”
That story has everything, that last one.
那个故事应有尽有，最后一个。
It really does. It's an entire novel in three lines.
确实如此。三行里写出了一整部小说。
So my favorite of all the variations on this is written by a student named Andrew-- maybe it's pronounced Vech-ee-oh-nay?
所以我最喜欢这个变体的版本是由一个名叫安德鲁的学生写的——也许发音是维基奥内？
Veck-ee-oh-nay, maybe.
也许是维基奥内。
Veck-ee-oh-nay, maybe. And could I ask you to read that? It's called "Sorry, But It Was Beautiful."
也许是维基奥内。我能请你读一下吗？它叫《抱歉，但这很美》。
Yeah. "Sorry I took your money and burned it, but it looked like the world falling apart when it crackled and burned. So I think it was worth it. After all, you can't see the world fall apart every day."
好的。“抱歉我拿了你的钱并把它烧了，但当它噼啪作响并燃烧时，它看起来就像世界分崩离析。所以我认为这是值得的。毕竟，你不能每天都看到世界分崩离析。”
That's the work of sixth grader Andrew Vecchione from a book by Kenneth Koch about teaching poetry to kids, in which he has them write their own versions of "This Is Just to Say." The book is called Rose, Where Did You Get That Red? Sean Cole says the poetry book of his that is easiest to find-- and he has assured me that it is not easy at all-- it's called ITTY CITY.
这是六年级学生安德鲁·维基奥内的作品，出自肯尼斯·科赫关于教孩子写诗的一本书，他在书中让他们写下自己的《这只是要说》版本。这本书叫《玫瑰，你从哪儿弄来那抹红？》。肖恩·科尔说他最容易找到的那本他的诗集——他向我保证这根本不容易——叫《微型城市》。
We asked some of our regular contributors to do their own variations on the poem. Here they are.
我们邀请了一些常规贡献者来创作他们自己的诗歌变体。它们在这儿。
"This Is Just to Say," by Sarah Vowell. I carved your name, not mine, into the arm of dad's chair. Sorry you were punished, but the wood was so gummy, and my knife was so sharp.
《这只是要说》，作者萨拉·沃威尔。我把你的名字，而不是我的，刻在了爸爸椅子的扶手上。抱歉你被惩罚了，但木头太胶着了，我的刀太锋利了。
"This Is Just to Say," by David Rakoff. At our wedding, I disappeared briefly to have sex with your sister up against the back of the Portosans. What can I say? The chardonnay was so fresh and cold, and I, so full of love and a sense of family. And I said, I'm sure one day we'll laugh about this. Well, by one day, I meant that day. And by we, I meant me. And by laugh, I meant laugh.
《这只是要说》，作者大卫·拉科夫。在我们的婚礼上，我短暂消失去和你的妹妹在波托桑厕所背面做了爱。我能说什么呢？霞多丽太新鲜、太冷了，而我，充满了爱和家庭感。我说，我相信总有一天我们会对此付之一笑。嗯，我说总有一天，我的意思就是那天。我说我们，我的意思就是我。我说笑，我的意思就是笑。
"This Is Just to Say," by Starlee Kine. One, I chose the other girl. I'm sorry. It's not just that I'm more attracted to her. It's also that she is more interesting. Two, I used your dog as an excuse to pick up girls at the dog park, which is especially tacky since I'm your boyfriend. Please forgive me. I'm really bad at being in a relationship, and I'm pretty sure I told you that when we first got together.
《这只是要说》，作者斯塔丽·凯恩。一，我选了另一个女孩。我很抱歉。并不是我更被她吸引。也是因为她更有趣。二，我用你的狗当借口在狗公园搭讪女孩，这尤其俗气，因为我是你的男朋友。请原谅我。我真的很不擅长经营恋爱关系，我非常肯定在我们刚在一起时就告诉你了。
"This Is Just to Say," by Jonathan Goldstein. This is just to say I have eaten the fruit of knowledge, but nothing happened. Not a word, no lightning or volcanoes, not even a drop of rain. So I was just wondering, are you there?
《这只是要说》，作者乔纳森·戈德斯坦。这只是想说我吃了知识的果实，但什么也没发生。没有一个字，没有闪电或火山，甚至连一滴雨都没有。所以我只是想知道，你在那儿吗？
"This Is Just to Say," by Shalom Auslander. One, I'm sorry you're overweight and drinking, and feeling like everything in your life is doomed to failure. But this is probably why Mom said I was her favorite. Two, it sucks, little doe, that I hit you with my car, but at least you weren't alive to watch the hunters shoot your children. Three, he was a troublemaker, OK? And didn't know when to shut up. Still, we never would have killed him if we'd known he was the Lord.
《这只是要说》，作者沙洛姆·奥斯兰德。一，我很抱歉你超重又酗酒，觉得你生命中的一切都注定失败。但这可能就是妈妈说我是她最爱的原因。二，真糟，小鹿，我用我的车撞了你，但至少你没活着看到猎人射杀你的孩子。三，他是个捣乱分子，好吗？不知道什么时候该闭嘴。尽管如此，如果我们知道他是上帝，我们永远不会杀了他。
"This Is Just to Say," by Heather O'Neill. Dear Mom, this is just to say I forgive you for eating all the plums, the apples, the pears, and even drinking the last of the orange juice. I forgive you for emptying Dad's bank account and for painting stars on our station wagon right before you got in and drove away. I forgive you for leaving us without even saying goodbye. Your plans were always so sweet, so delicious, and so cold.
《这只是要说》，作者希瑟·奥尼尔。亲爱的妈妈，这只是想说我原谅你吃了所有的李子、苹果、梨子，甚至喝光了最后一点橙汁。我原谅你清空了爸爸的银行账户，并在你上车开走之前给我们的旅行车画上了星星。我原谅你离开我们甚至连再见都没说。你的计划总是那么甜，那么美味，那么冷。
[MUSIC - FOREIGNER, "COLD AS ICE"]
[音乐 - 外国人乐队《冷若冰霜》]
Our program was produced today by Sarah Koenig and myself, with Alex Blumberg, Jane Marie, Lisa Pollak, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Senior producer for today's show is Julie Snyder. Production help from Seth Lind. Music help today from Jessica Hopper. Additional help on today's rerun from Bim Adewunmi, Aviva DeKornfeld, Jarrett Floyd, Stowe Nelson, and Matt Tierney.
我们今天的节目由萨拉·凯尼格和我制作，亚历克斯·布隆伯格、简·玛丽、丽莎·波拉克、罗宾·塞米恩、阿丽莎·希普和南希·厄普代克参与。今天节目的高级制片人是朱莉·斯奈德。Seth Lind协助制作。Jessica Hopper协助音乐。Bim Adewunmi、Aviva DeKornfeld、Jarrett Floyd、Stowe Nelson和Matt Tierney协助今天的重播。
Thanks today to Dave Dickerson and Chris Gethard, David Rakoff, one of our longtime contributors who wrote a variation of "This Is Just to Say," in that last act, he died back in 2012. He is not frozen, but his books are still out there.
感谢戴夫·迪克森和克里斯·格哈德，大卫·拉科夫，我们的长期贡献者之一，他在最后一幕写了一个《这只是要说》的变体，他于2012年去世了。他没有被冷冻，但他的书还在流传。
Our website, ThisAmericanLife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia, who reminds you, don't mess with him.
我们的网站，ThisAmericanLife.org。《这一美国生活》由公共广播交易所PRX负责送达公共广播电台。一如既往地感谢我们节目的共同创始人，托里·马拉蒂亚先生，他提醒你，别惹他。
I am loaded. I own my own house.
我很有钱。我有自己的房子。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带更多《这一美国生活》的故事回来。